et écoute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que ça prend un animateur pour
comprendre
et ça fait peur parce qu'on se dit qu'il
y a peut-être certains pays où en fait
c'est OK d'être raciste à la cool à
visage découvert quoi et personne ne dit
rien c'est raciste homophobe le
présentateur met longtemps réagir là la
chaîne n'avait pas encore fait de
communiquer officielle et les joueurs
argentins j'aimerais bien quand même
qu'il arrive mais si l'emblème du foot
mondial ça sera bien qui dit c'est
dégueulasse et tout ça c'est honteux
Cyril franchement c'est honteux c'est
immonde
une vraie claque dans la gueule et là
c'est replante
[Musique]
est-ce que ça veut dire écouter faites
pas c'est le mot il joue en France mais
ils viennent tous d'Angola comme c'est
mignon ils vont courir ils embrassent
des tronces comme l'homo de Mbappe sa
mère est nigériane son père et
camerounais mais dans le document
nationalité française
des patrons de l'équipe argentine il
faut il faut laisser il doit dire un
truc je suis désolé
gentil bah si ah tu crois qu'on doit
dénoncer c'est comme si toi tu avais pas
vu TPMP jeudi s'il l'a pas vu
calme-toi calme-toi